so wir haben h eine Kamera mit
Gesichtserkennung das ist sensationell
aber ob sie das nächste Gesicht erkennen
wird ich weiß es nicht es ist nämlich
man es ist unschwer zu erkennen das
Gezeichnete Ich hallo sie nehmen auch am
bundeswision Song Contest
teil wie ist es denn dazu gekommen
vielleicht mal doch die Maske weil das
ist z Pseudonym aber du zeigst doch dein
Gesicht ab und zu mal oder auch bitte
nur für uns okay also gezeichnet ich wie
ist es dazu gekommen wie kommt man zum
bundeswischen
songkontest ich dachte ich wurde
ausgewählt persönlich von Stefan Rab so
wurde es mir erklärt ja der macht das
persönlich der macht das persönlich der
guckt wo sind in welchem Bundesland was
für Bands ganz vorne mit dabei und die
wählt aus denke ich okay also da gibt's
keine Kommunikation drüber was heißt
Kommunikation so nach dem Motto du bist
es
weil ja bei mir hier natürlich ganz klar
weil ich dem König von Preußen sehr
ähnlich sehe und in meinem Schloss in
Potzdam residiere und da war klar gut
das Gezeichnete Ich muss es machen für
Brandenburg das glaube ich jetzt alles
nicht so
ganz ich glaube schon dass es eher an
der Musik liegt ja die Musik ja ja das
ist ja beim gezeichnet nicht da riecht
die Musik besonders
gut mal ganz ehrlich was zeichnet das
gezeig
ich
a das Gezeichnete Ich was zeichnete es
aus ja Gott vielleicht eine Chronologie
des Scheiterns in erster Linie die hat
wahrscheinlich jeder auch vor Augen aber
da gab es auch immer kurze Lichtblicke
des Glücks der
Liebe ja der freudigen Erwartung auch
der bitteren Enttäuschung und das alles
malt und pinselt in jeden von uns hinein
so auch in mich das heißt du bist ein
großer Poet wenn ich das auch aus der
Hüfte geschassen oh Gott das war weiß
ich nicht aber ja ich ich liebe es schon
bisschen zu dichten und zu schreiben
deswegen mache ich auch Musik und Kunst
gut aber das macht ja nicht jeder viele
den ist bei stehen steht die Musik im
Vordergrund bei dir ist es dann eher der
Text würde ich jetzt mal so sagen nee
nee nee ist vielleicht sogar genau
umgekehrt also ich die Musik ist noch
besser als seine Texte die Musik ach
Gott besser und schlechter ist immer
schwierig bei Musik man versucht
natürlich ich versuche das auszudrücken
was ja was in mir darum fleht gesagt zu
werden sowohl musikalisch als auch
textlich du hast gerade gesprochen von
einer Chronologie des Scheiterns aber
davon kann man doch nicht sprechen wenn
man hier beim bundeswischen Songcontest
dann gelandet ist nee das gibt sich ja
das kann man ja auch jedem nur als Tipp
geben am Anfang ist alles immer
scheitern und verwerfen und noch mal und
zerreißen und wieder entwerfen und so
weiter und so weiter man darf der
einzige Trick ist nur man darf nicht
aufhören damit irgendwann ist man dann
auch beim bonusvision Songcontest gut
also das Rezept für den Erfolg ist Spaß
am schalern
äh ja da gibt's auch ein Buch die Kunst
des scheiderns von äh von einem
großartigen Künstler Konstantin Wecker
das empfehle ich jedem jungen Künstler
gut okay was empfiehlst du den den
Youtube Zuschauern äh als Gewinner beim
bundeswischen Song Contest rechnest du
dir Chancen aus
ähm also
der Mathematiker in mir der sagt auf
jeden Fall unter den ersten 16 da werde
ich verortet sein der Träumer und der
Größen warnsin gesagt natürlich ganz
Klar Platz 1 und
der der Hindu in mir sagt es geht nicht
um verlieren und gewinnen Spaß muss es
machen gut aber trotzdem an alle Leute
die dieses Video gesehen haben votet für
ihn ruft an guckt dieses Video so oft
ihr könnt favorisiert es thumbs up und
so weiter wenn ihr ihn oben sehen wollt
und wenn ihr schon auf Youtube einen
kleinen Trend setzen wollt und
was würdest du sagen was ist der Grund
dich zu wählen
m das ist eine interessante Frage da
fällt mir natürlich spontan gar keinen
Grund ein da gibt's ja auch so eine so
ein Zitat von bertr and Russell glaube
ich der Verein der mich aufnimmt in dem
möchte ich gar nicht sein oder so
ähnlich müssen wir noch mal nachschlagen
aber so ungefähr sollte mein Satz la gut
okay meine Damen und Herren wir setzen
das Gespräch fort im philosophischen
Quartett im CDF dann zu späterer
Sendezeit ansonsten mein Tipp es gibt
noch Karten für den bundeswision Song
Contest also solange die Sendung noch
nicht gelaufen ist in die forten zusehen
sind guckt an den entsprechenden Orten
es sind noch ein paar Plätze
frei